Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier,
and welcome to Tattletail.
"Open your Christmas present early"??
I don't want to do that!
I wanna be a good boi! :'3
Oh no! :'DD
Oh-ho no-ho!
Hai! *laughs*
Tattletail: Me Tattletail...
Me love you! :3
Okay??
Tattletail: Let's play a game!
Mark: Oh okay.
Mark: All right, let's play a game!
Mark: Playing...
Mark: Are we going to break it?
FFFFFFFFUCK!
*knocks and footsteps*
WHO'S THERE?! O-o
Ohhhh... o-o
*Shakes flashlight violently.*
*Le gasp.* O-o
AYYYYYY!
I HATE THIS!!!
Mark: FUCK!!
Mama: Mama's looking after you~
NOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO--
All right. I'm gonna stop being such a big baby -w-
AHHH! FUCKING GOD DAMN IT!
Okay maybe if I go down to the basement I'll be safe??! *shakes flashlight*
YEAH, THAT SOUNDS RIGHT!
FFFFFFFFFFFFUuUuUuCK!
I just need to groom my Furby! -.-
Tattletail: Give me a treat!
Mark: AH, SHUT THE FUCK UP! YOU'RE GONNA STARVE AND BE DIRTY TILL THE END OF YOUR DAYS!
Mark: YOU LITTLE SHIT!
Tattletail: Give me a treat!
NAO!!
WHAT THE FUCK IS HAPPENING?!
"Let Tattletail join the seance"?
Tattletails: No more Mama!
What the fuck!?
*Whining and crying* D':
Oh my gooooooooood! QnQ
*Coolsongs - Back that Ass Up!!*
Check out more of Mark's cool videos!
Leave a like!
Comment YOUR favorite moment in the comments below!
And then,Subscribe to mark and LixianTv!
Buh-bye y'all!